This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Rob.
And I'm Georgina.
Now Georgina, you recently mentioned in one 6 Minute English program
about NFTs and that you had a collection of Pokemon cards when you were younger.
Yes, I did and I still can't find them.
Why did you bring that up?
Well, Pokemon started out as a video game series that turned into anime movies and trading cards
among other things. And in this program, we're talking about a video game character
that is iconic, a word which means widely known and recognised.
That character's name is Super Mario.
Ah, I spent many hours of my childhood playing with Nintendo's Super Mario
or his rival, Sega's Sonic the Hedgehog.
Now these days, video games are everywhere and people of all ages enjoy playing them.
There's also competitive e-sports events where gamers compete for what are often
considerable amounts of money.
Yes, and there are also streamers that appear on platforms like Twitch and YouTube
who have become celebrities in their own right.
Talking about celebrities, I have a question about the famous character we're talking about in
this program. Many people remember Super Mario brothers as being the first time we saw Mario,
but he first appeared in another game, which was it? Was it A, the legend of Zelda, B Donkey Kong
or C Pokemon?
I'm not sure about that. I can't remember him being in Pokemon, so I'll go for A, the legend
of Zelda. Okay, Georgina, we'll find out if you're right at the end of the program.
So, we established at the start of the program that these days, the video games industry is thriving.
True, but it wasn't always that way. It's hard to imagine now, but in the 1980s, the console market
was struggling, particularly in the US.
So bad that they ended up burying thousands of copies of it in a desert because nobody
liked it. So we'd had the, especially in America, this didn't happen so much in Europe,
but in America, there'd just been lots and lots of software and none of it was all that great.
There hadn't been anything really revolutionary in some years, so the video game boom was
really falling off the cliff and Nintendo is what rescued it in the US especially.
Kess and McDonald used the term a flood of, meaning a large number in a short period of time,
to describe the number of games that were coming out. She used cited, which means reference
or noted, when talking about the game ET being a reference for a factor in the collapse of the
console market. And she said boom, a sudden period of growth. So as ET was mentioned, as a factor
in the collapse, many people say that Super Mario Bros. was the reason that video games really took
off, especially in the US. It's interesting to consider what might have been if its creator,
Shiguru Miyamoto, had never created that character. The question is why is that game so popular?
What made it so fun to play? Here is Kess and McDonald speaking again with Peter White on the BBC
World Service program You and Yours. Explaining why Mario is just so popular and what makes the
original game so satisfying to play? It's just such a joy to play. It's running and jumping
and it's the joy of movement. When you play even the original Super Mario Bros. you just feel the
sense of joy in your movement. And it's one of the greatest games I've ever made. And a lot of
games from 35 years ago are basically unplayable now. They might have been a step to something
greater, but Mario is one of those few that really holds up today as well that did then.
Kess and McDonald said that some games from 35 years ago are unplayable, so not possible to play
them. But she said that Mario holds up, a term used to say that something standards or quality
has not lessened. It certainly does hold up. In fact, I played it the other day and I had lots of
fun with it. It reminded me of my childhood and it's still as good now as it was then.
Which reminds me of your quiz question, Rob? Yes. In my quiz question, I asked your Gina,
which game had the first appearance of that famous plumber, Mario? I went for A, the Legend of Zelda.
Ah, which is wrong, I'm afraid. Mario's first appearance was in Donkey Kong, and his creator,
Shiguru Miyamoto, never thought he would be that popular. Well, I guess we've already learnt
something today. Let's recap the vocabulary from today's programme about Super Mario, starting
with iconic, famously associated with something and instantly recognisable. Then we had a flood of,
which means a large amount of something in a short space of time. Sighted means reference as or
noted. Boom relates to explosion and means a short period of sudden growth. Unplayable describes
something that can't be played or a game that is very difficult to enjoy. And finally, holds up
means that the quality or standard of something hasn't changed and still looks good or plays well.
That's all for this programme. Bye for now. Bye!